concerns are growing about the spread of
Kovac 19 among US service members on the
Japanese island of Okinawa at least 141
troops at Marine Corps bases are now
infected with the virus there the
islands governor has now confirmed the
first known case of the virus being
transmitted by a service member to local
resident ramie you know sensi reports
now from okinawa the Ospreys still
deploy from okinawa the US military's
Keystone in the Pacific even as the
Marine Corps wages a public health
battle against coronavirus Lieutenant
Commander Margaret Moore is a senior
medical officer how bad is it my
assessment is that it's not as bad as it
possibly could be because healthy people
are getting better from this disease
Colonel Neal Owens met us at the joint
kovat response cell the nerve center of
the military's coronavirus response
there is no off-base Liberty authorized
to stop the spread up to 40,000 Marines
and their families have been placed on
restricted movement orders if you live
out in town you go home and you come to
work and that's really the only
interaction you have off the base a
different situation from the fourth of
July this video posted to social media
allegedly shows US personnel partying no
masks no social distancing while
restrictions were looser at the time
upset locals including the governor are
now blaming the Marine Corps for
Okinawa's covert search is there truth
to that so as of right now we have not
found any connection between the July
4th celebration in any positive case
that we've identified the presence of US
troops in Okinawa remains a point of
frustration for local residents in 2016
protests flared after an ex-marine was
accused of raping and murdering a 20
year old Japanese woman he was later
convicted and sentenced to life in
prison
we are so so angry 80 year-old peace
activists Suseo takazato was born and
raised here
she says that over the years allegations
against US servicemen have also included
drunk driving and sexual assault what
are you demanding of the US military to
evacuate every u.s.
three from okinawa because we have been
suffering 75 years already and the US
Marine Corps told CBS news two other
things one that all of those service
members who contracted corona virus are
only experiencing weak symptoms and that
the core remains operationally ready and
ready to combat any threat here in
asia-pacific Tony
Ramey innocencio in Okinawa for a
Streamy thank you very much